like what an odd dear 2017 will be for
you President Obama was good for the New
York Times what's a president Trump
going to be like well I think I mean the
key thing is is we're living through a
gigantic new very unpredictable story in
many ways it's the story is multifaceted
is linked I mean it's a instability in
Europe Breck's it's part of our but only
part of that a wild card in the White
House it should be a great year for new
so in think about the news business we
the raw material that we make money out
of is going to be in plentiful supply
and suddenly I look at where we are and
as I mentioned in the beginning here
without question a theme as I was
unprepared for the level of uncertainty
that I see her today John McCloy how
important are these speeches today did
they come out in are they safe speeches
particularly president G and then he
just moves on to the next of the adding
presidency is likely a very safe speech
because in a sense he's got the forum
open Tomb there there is a much American
participation he comes along and he will
look I expect like a sort of credible
alternative leader he wants that's what
he has to do Theresa May has a much much
more difficult problem where she she is
so far sort of failed to get across
exactly what she's doing or she now
seems to be coming down one side of the
fence but for people here it's it's
exactly the wrong answer look at this in
the swirl when we go up to the
inauguration speech which I don't think
anybody really understands where that
speech is going it's a set of speeches
and then we go to the March fifteenth
Netherlands election yeah but I've ever
wondered rights never anything but John
on your point it does seem that a lot of
CEOs here I'm more worried about brexit
than for the moon they are about Donald
Trump but I think with brexit the one of
the things people are resting with is
the pacing that the you know today's
speech it's going to be an important
milestone but this is going to be years
and years before ultimate certainty
arrives I think for businesses not just
a lot of American businessman in New
York ask me questions about brexit it's
the it's the extent but the very length
of time the uncertainty is going to last
which makes planning so difficult
because it's a negotiation right John I
did this today what can we learn today
if Briggs it means Briggs it it
automatically almost assumes that we
have to lose
to some extent yes if the single market
goes that's a huge deal it's a bit like
when those negotiations whether it could
be the shortest negotiation ever where
the British say we great once done
European say help us with your globe
both of your global perspectives I would
suggest not only is it the may speech
and the importance of it and maybe she
travels to Davos later in the week and
redux us the speech but it's overlaid
upon the president-elect talking about
thirty-five percent tariffs with BMW is
it really a reaction to brexit but also
to this idea of where we'll trade be
mark so to me it what's the thing about
this is it feels to me that instead of
the UK leamy EU in the kind of steady
state that the fundamentals of of global
free trade and the balance between
national interest and kind of
globalization is also in play and one of
the reasons I think Theresa May may well
be thinking about caution even what she
says today is we don't know what the
relationship between the US and Europe
is going to be in terms of frayed we
don't know because of the elections you
mentioned the Netherlands elections
after that prevailing after that we have
in in April and French elections there's
so many variables here that if I was may
I'd be in a sense step by step she's got
it she's got to get some more principles
out today but I wouldn't go too crazy
traitors now that the notion of sexiest
torrid than it's been for a long time in
a previous life both mark and I used to
be involved in publications we don't
heavily anchored in free trade but yeah
this this sort of age of globalization
the big question whether that's coming
to an end or not i think is fascinating
and there is a definite danger that if
you end up with an American China
confrontation increasing help us with
yesterday essentially Chancellor Merkel
suggesting to mr. Trump we don't need
you and that reverberation throughout
Europe and this idea of a NATO's is a
antiquity I mean again I'd be quite
careful if you're a politician so you
have your home base so you're talking to
your own electorate to do that in Davos
no surveillance breaks clusive get there
right away right for exclusive you talk
to your own person to make sure that you
get realized it mark talk to us a little
bit about digital subscription right so
at December he said you added two
hundred thousand unique digital
subscribers you want to increase that so
we haven't actually given final numbers
for the last quarter of last year but we
have we said several times to the market
over the course of November and December
big big big numbers I mean we were
seeing numbers in that quarter which
we've never seen one before and although
there was an initial surge we don't
expect to continue in the same way we do
think that the new cycle and also to
some extent specifically the character
the new president means that we're going
to go and seeing brisk business do you
think this is the future of news for up
market news that night money is about
Mike my view is by far the most secure
way of paying for high quality
journalism he's asking consumers to
engage form a relationship with a news
provider and to pay yes I do believe
that yeah help me with the new
competition and I particularly look at
the massive capital that mr. Bezos has
put into the Washington Post how will
the industry respond to another major
player in the game with a lot of honey
firstly hats off to Jeff Bezos for
putting serious money into in to
integrate journalism and I'd say you
know i mean i think the washington post
is a formal competitor you don't one
doesn't always like that on stories but
i think it's great that they're back at
with you they're getting back into the
game and of course you know i mean
obviously the trump stories to some
extent of washington store it's it's
good news good news for them what I want
to say though is I think the fate of the
great news providers of the world is
going to be less about our kind of peer
competition a much more about our
relationship with the big digital
platforms with the future of advertising
the kind of structural shifts were
seeing in advertising in many ways I
think it's the it's the bigger forces at
work around us rather than you know will
the wall street journal be up and the
Washington Post down or vice versa sort
of thing I think that's still going to
be part of the story but it's a smaller
part of the story I made you measure it
more by circulation now or by
advertising I think I
I think of advertising as being an
incredibly important revenue stream but
in the end a secondary revenue stream
and so I'm what I'm specifically
interested in is the largest possible
number of deep relationships and you
know every person who's got a deep
relationship with the New York Times
needs to be a subscriber but
subscriptions are really good indication
of a deep relationship and I think it's
that it's that core engaged audience and
how big you can hold out how big do you
think you can take that I've said
publicly I think that we should be we
should have an ambition of getting to 10
million digital subscriber no I believe
that many of those how many of those
outside America let's say a third of
those